you guys time for another flickers of
fear
this is one of the reviews that i've
been looking forward to the longest
because this is one of my favorite
horror movies of all time
this is the haunting from 1963.
i've written extensively about this
movie i've written extensively about the
book by shirley jackson which is also
awesome
obviously a lot of people are very very
familiar with the netflix series the
haunting of hill house which is loosely
based on shirley jackson's book
obviously expands on the story a lot and
you know
a lot of liberties were taken with it's
it's an awesome series i'm not saying
that but
this is actually more of a
straightforward adaptation of the book
itself and if you haven't seen it you
totally should because
especially if you're into
kind of like foundational horror films
if you're into haunted house stuff this
is definitely definitely one that you
need to see because i feel like
a lot of
later haunted house stories especially
kind of your slow burn ones from the
1970s uh were big time influenced by not
only the novel which i believe came out
in 1959 but also this movie which came
out 1963. so this was directed by
robert wise who just prior to this had
done west side story and just after this
did sound of music so he was kind of
known for doing he was a musicals guy
but he also did i think he did the day
the earth stood still he did like other
things so he did some sci-fi as well
honestly of all the films of his that
i've seen um he's made like a [ __ ] ton
of like really iconic ones but this one
is easily my favorite i mean this one
and the innocence are probably my
favorite uh 60s horror films and i just
love the whole entire
atmosphere of this it's just so [ __ ]
great like the cinematography it's the
sound design everything about this is so
so good and this is a movie that
like i said if you're real into like
haunted house stuff and you don't like
some of the over saturated like ooh
ghosty kind of
cgi fests that they had you know not so
much nowadays because i feel like
movies like this more are coming back
now but you know in the 90s and 2000s um
you know we had all these kind of like
crazy cgi ghost movies i just kind of
feel like if you really want to see an
example of making a scary movie without
really showing anything this is the
thing that i always uh this is the movie
that i always point out because there
are essentially there are some special
effects in this
but
nothing like you never see any ghosts
you never really see anything
that's terrifying but the way that it's
shot uh the sound design the reactions
of the characters just everything about
it
is just kind of a skew and it's just
calculated to it's just you know the
whole movie is just permeated with kind
of this sense of unease interestingly
too robert wise insisted that this movie
be shot in black and white even though
yes that doesn't seem weird to people
nowadays uh but 1963 i mean most movies
were in color then there were a few that
were still black and white obviously but
he just said i i don't think this would
look the same in color it's like these
types of movies really need to be in
black and white so
uh you know he did film it in black and
white and you know it it really does
lend something to like a kind of i don't
know like a weird timelessness to it i
guess because like i said the
cinematography is just this beautiful
luminous looking
uh cinematography and it's just like so
great i think it was even like in this
contract
that this movie
never be colorized because you know like
in the 90s i feel like was it the 90s
where i think it was ted turner you know
where they were colorizing like all
these old movies um and they never
looked all that good i don't know why
they bothered but uh i mean robert wise
was basically put in his contract he's
like never ever colorized this movie uh
it's not allowed and uh thank christ for
that because i just can't i just don't
think and i'm not saying it would still
be a good movie i just don't think it
would be as effective and i think i said
that we were talking about carnival of
souls the other day and i had watched a
colorized version of that
you know and it's still a good movie i
love carnival of souls but
something about it being in black and
white just is so much better and i and i
just kind of feel like the same thing
would have happened if somebody would
have colorized this it's still a great
movie but
it would have lost some of its allure i
think
so basically this follows the plot of
shirley jackson's novel pretty closely
and like i said this is
essentially a haunted house novel but
it's also like a psychological horror
novel and that was one of the things
that i always really liked i mean this
is easily the shirley jackson book is
easily my my favorite haunted house
novel of all time and like i said this
is easily my favorite haunted house
movie of all time you're never really
entirely sure
i mean i'm not saying that
it is a supernatural novel i think even
shirley jackson came out and said yeah
the you know hill house is actually
haunted but you're not sure how much of
the haunting is attributable
to the main character of eleanor her
psychological and emotional fragility is
she
seeing things that other people aren't
seeing is the house maybe taking
advantage of her because of this
emotional fragility is she somehow
manifesting uh the haunting it's just
like kind of all of these different uh
things that i think it's like really
cool and i think it's really good that
the movie kind of goes into a lot of
that too like a lot of the um stuff that
was in the book where it's just kind of
this ambiguous you're not really sure
how much of
eleanor's mental breakdown is sort of
like mirrored by the house whether she's
making the house
do it or whether the house is
manipulating her you're never really
entirely sure but that was that's one
thing that i really like about the novel
and also i think they captured that like
really really well so in case you guys
don't know like i said it seems old hat
nowadays like this type of setup but for
the time it was like pretty
you know a lot of haunted house movies
that came later uh owe a big debt to
this movie
so basically you have a guy who's like a
parapsychologist anthropologist uh type
guy
uh named dr mark way john mark way
and he has been wanting to look for he's
skeptical like in a scientist type of
way but he's also wants to look into you
know the paranormal wants evidence of
the afterlife and he has decided that
the best way to do this
is to do a several day investigation at
this place called hill house now hill
house uh is this huge mansion that was
built by a guy named hugh crane 90 years
previously
and it had it's had a reputation for
being a bad place like ever since it was
first built so it's it's one of those
ones and i think he even uses this
phrasing
in the movie that it was a place that
was born bad because even
ukraine has built this house like for
his young wife and before the wife even
sees it like they're coming up there in
the carriage or whatever and before she
even sees it like the carriage
overturned and she is killed
and then you know there's kind of like a
um a voiceover at the beginning of the
movie where dr markway is kind of like
talking about the history of the house
and all the tragedies that happened
there
so after she dies um he ends up
remarrying i believe and then like the
second wife like then they have a
daughter then the daughter gets like the
second wife is also killed i think she
falls down the stairs and then the
daughter abigail grows up and kind of
inherits the house
and then she has this companion
that uh stays with her into her old age
and that companion ends up hanging
herself in the uh in the library like
above this spiral staircase and that
kind of becomes like a focal point for
eleanor's character because the
character of the companion and the
character of eleanor are supposed to be
like mirror images of one another i
don't they go into that a little bit in
the movie i think that's more of a thing
in the book sometimes i get the two
confused because i've read the book so
many times and i've seen the movie so
many times that a lot of times and
they're so similar that like a lot of
times they overlap
um i do think they bring up the thing
about the companion uh especially
there's one scene like in a greenhouse
where there's this statue of like all
these people and um you know they
they're saying oh it's maybe this figure
here this statue here is the companion
oh that looks like you eleanor so they
are like um making a parallel between
her and the uh and the companion who
hanged herself
so dr markway has got uh has decided to
uh do an investigation in hill house
because of its reputation the most
haunted house in america whatever
um so to do that he thinks that the best
thing to do when he kind of combs
through the annals of you know all these
psychic societies and things like that
like looking for people who have had
either some kind of like psychic powers
quote unquote or have had some kind of
paranormal experiences happen to them
and he thinks that it would be a good
idea to bring these people to hill house
to help with the investigation because
he thinks maybe it will like spur
something into happening that he can
then go on and you know say definitively
yes this house is haunted whatever he's
trying to prove
essentially prove the paranormal is what
he's trying to do
so he gets permission from the woman who
owns the house uh this woman named mrs
sanderson she's like she's elderly and
uh so she is kind of like yeah i'm gonna
die she doesn't live there nobody lives
there but she's like okay well you can
do your investigation but you have to uh
take my nephew along because you know
i'm to die soon and he's the next in
line he's going to inherit the house and
you know so take him with you is kind of
like insurance or something like that
so dr markway is going to take the
nephew whose name is luke
he's played by russ tamblyn who was also
in west side story if you didn't know
like right before this was made uh so
he's gonna go along as well to kind of
check out what he's gonna inherit like
after his aunt dies
now even though dr markway approaches
like quite a long list of people that he
thinks would uh be good for this
experiment one by one they all drop out
except for two women
one of these women is eleanor
lance in the movie she's named eleanor
lance in the book she's eleanor vance
i'm not really sure why they changed
that but whatever um
she's played by julie harris and uh the
other one is just a woman named theodora
uh whose name who's played by claire
bloom now theodora is actually a psychic
and she is supposedly they kind of go
into this
dr markway when he introduces her to the
other guests um she's basically like she
did those zener cards or whatever um she
got like 19 out of 20. so she can
basically like read minds essentially so
she's like a psychic eleanor is called
there or is you know sent a letter and
responds to it because when she was a
child she essentially had like a
poltergeist incident like stones fell on
her house and even though she kind of
denies that it happened it's still in
the record somewhere and uh you know so
dr markway
uh found out about it now like i said he
had contacted a lot of different people
but these two were the only ones to
actually show up
now the character of eleanor um who they
who is essentially she's called nell
through most of the movie that's like
her nickname
she's kind of like a really interesting
character she's kind of like a neurotic
character she's very sheltered
she's spent most of her adult life if
not all of her adult life caring for her
invalid mother so she's never really had
a life of her own
because she's just essentially been a
caretaker and she couldn't really
leave or like go out and do anything
now her mother has died two months prior
to the events of the movie
and she's kind of like sleeping on the
couch in the in her sister and
brother-in-law's house
and interestingly even though she pays
rent
and even though she paid for half of
their car
they treat her as though she's a child
now
maybe some of that could be like
understandable because yes she hasn't
really been out in the world she's just
been spent years and years like taking
care of their mother and hasn't really
gone anyplace
but she is an adult and the fact that
they
you know she paid for half of the car
and they're just like no you can't take
it and she has to like sit there and
practically beg them to let her go to
this
to hill house for this you know thing
and they just don't want to let her go
they just treat her like she's a child
even though her sister i'm not sure if
her sister's supposed to be older i
think in the book she's older but in the
movie the actress playing her
looks the same age or maybe even a
little bit younger so it just comes off
as just kind of like
these two just like no you just have to
stay here and sleep on the couch in this
house so eleanor's not at a good place
in her life and they pretty much hint
from the very beginning because a lot of
the movie is done like in her voiceover
and stuff that she's not i don't want to
say that she's not entirely there but
like i said she's very naive she's very
vulnerable she's just not super super
emotionally stable she's never
really developed an identity of her own
you know she doesn't really she hasn't
really had any profound like personal
relationships or anything like that like
she's never been married or had a
boyfriend or everything she's just cared
for her mother pretty much her whole
entire adult life so as i said she's
very very sheltered um and not
surprisingly that is not super like
emotionally healthy
so when she gets summoned to go to hill
house it's almost kind of like this big
you know this big revelation it's like
oh hey i can have a life of my own i can
be independent um you know i can go
there they're expecting me i can belong
somewhere because i kind of feel like
that's one of the main things one of the
main thrusts of her character and one of
the things that
causes all these problems when she gets
to hill house is that she
never felt like she belonged anywhere
like she didn't feel like she belonged
in the world so the fact that somebody
actually like contacted her and was like
hey we want you to come do this thing
you know she kind of felt a sense of
belonging for the first time in her life
and she didn't really want to let that
go so essentially she um ends up
i want to say she steals the car
but she did pay for half of it uh so i
don't know why they wouldn't just let
her have it but her sister and the
husband are just kind of like no you
can't have it but so she just takes it
like without their knowledge and drives
up to hill house so she's like the first
one to get there so as i said so they
all kind of come to the house she's the
first one to get there she meets the
creepy um
the groundskeeper guy uh dudley and then
mrs dudley who's like the housekeeper
mrs dudley she has like a gray i can't
remember the name of the actress that
plays her but she just has this kind of
great
when all the guests get there she kind
of has this like spooky spiel she's like
you know like in later horror movies
like in friday the 13th they have the
dude that comes in it's like you're
doomed it's like she's the she has that
kind of role it's not as over the top as
that but she has this like prepared
spiel
uh that she says to each one of them
like as they show up it's like you know
no one lives any nearer than town no one
will come any closer than that you know
so she has all these other no one will
hear you if you need help and so she
just like says the same thing to all of
them and she's like super creepy and
it's like it's and it's funny they kind
of like
i don't want to say they make like a
little bit of a joke about it but when
theodora's character gets there she does
kind of like make a little bit of joke
about it and it's just kind of like
funny but also kind of unsettling i
don't know it's like hard to say so um
one by one all of them kind of show up
and they um you know kind of get to know
one another there's actually
interestingly there's kind of like a
strange dynamic you know pretty much
from the jump between nell and theodora
now nell like i said seems like she's
very emotionally like fragile she's very
kind of like needy she wants to belong
somewhere so she really kind of like
you know theodora who they call theo is
you know nice to her and so she's kind
of like oh we're gonna be best friends
forever all this other kind of stuff so
she like jumps right in there uh theo
it's interesting because in the book
they do she do she does actually like
imply that theo is a lesbian um i think
i can't remember if it's more outright
in the book or the movie because the
movie it's not it's empty they never
come right out and say that theo is a
lesbian but um
it's very very strongly implied and
actually people audiences nowadays
watching it would have no problem being
like oh you know she's a lesbian but i
don't know like you know because of
censorship and stuff like that like in
the 60s maybe you had to be a little
more subtle about it like i said now
it'd be just be super obvious but yeah
so i don't know it might have been a
little bit clearer in the book but i
can't really remember uh what it was but
so theo almost kind of has at first like
seems to have a little bit of a romantic
interest in nell nell doesn't really
seem to pick up on it because like i
said she's very naive interestingly nell
starts kind of having some romantic
feelings toward dr markway who is
married although she doesn't know that
until later on uh and that is one thing
that causes like this kind of like big
conflict uh later on in the movie
so all four of them gather there uh dr
markway kind of tells him about the
history of the house and what he's
hoping to achieve and then they all kind
of like go to bed now the great thing
about this movie and like i said it's
you know i can spoil it obviously
because it's very old like a lot of
people know the story of this like i
said the netflix series
is a lot different than the book and a
lot different than this but it does have
like a lot of the same touchstones and
stuff i just think this is one of those
movies especially if you're into older
horror like i said foundational type
horror movies haunted house movies this
is definitely one you need to see
because this is
this is really like an idealized
portrait of less is more you know what i
mean that really this really illustrates
that principle so so well because you
never see
a ghost in this you never see anything
mostly what you you hear a lot of things
like i said the sound design in this is
really really great because it's just
like this creepy like the first thing
that happens like the first night that
they're there nell and theo are in
adjoining rooms and they start hearing
this like almighty thundering noise um i
think theo compares it to like somebody
just knocked on the door with a
cannonball or something like that it's
just really loud like booming
noise and it's really really loud and it
seems like it's moving like down the
halls and then it kind of like rattles
the doorknob and there's like freaking
out and all this other kind of stuff but
then when they meet back up later on
there's you know when they meet back up
with dr markway and luke later on
they're like didn't you guys hear that
it was like something loud it sounded
like [ __ ] bombs and stuff and they
were like no we found this there was
this dog inside the house and we
followed it out to the garden so
obviously even from the beginning hill
house is like trying to separate them
so so it's mostly that kind of stuff
where they can just hear things also
from pretty early on in the film uh you
can tell that either
eleanor has decided that hill house is
her place is home to her has been
calling her this is the place she's been
looking for where she's gonna belong her
entire life
um so the fact that she has that feeling
maybe uh if hill house is actually
haunted which it probably is uh maybe
the house is
using that aspect of her personality in
order to manipulate her into getting
what it wants it seems like that's kind
of what the movie is saying because
pretty early on the house seems to
target eleanor in particular because the
i think the just the second day they're
there
um there's like a big somebody has
written in chalk
uh on the wall like really big eleanor
it says help eleanor come home kind of
are like accusing each other of it
and stuff um you know theo even accuses
nells like what you know did you do that
just to get attention that kind of stuff
so there's kind of all this ambiguity
about whether nell is doing the stuff
for attention which i don't think she is
but i think that her vulnerability her
i almost want to say it's narcissism
it's not her self-absorption i guess is
making her a target of the house in
particular
because
the house is targeting her vulnerability
and her vulnerability being she feels
like she doesn't belong anywhere and
this is the first place where you know
people have actually like
been wanting to hang out with her and
talk to her and this seemed like the
first
place where she was home you know what i
mean it's like even she even like thinks
things because like i said a lot of this
is in voice over but like when mrs
dudley like shows her to her room she
calls it my very own room later on like
when [ __ ] starts to go even more
sideways and dr markway you know thinks
maybe we're all in danger so he wants to
put nell and theo in the same room she
gets really upset about it because she's
like hey that's my room you know she
doesn't want someone else invading it
even though her and theo had been kind
of getting along so the the fact that
the house is like targeting her is kind
of like one of the best things about
the about this movie i think it's just
kind of like her
you know her weaknesses like it's almost
like the house like exploiting her
weaknesses and targeting her in
particular because it knows she's the
weakest one uh one of the best scenes in
this too and like i said you don't
really see anything but some of the best
scenes in this are nell like waking up
in the middle of the night and just
seeing like these shadows on the wall
and it's just kind of like hearing these
creepy noises like sounding like a
little girl laughing but then sounding
like a little girl like kind of being
hurt um and her like freaking out about
it and then she thinks that she's
holding theo's hand all this time like
theo is like holding her hand because
it's dark and stuff like that and then
her waking up and it's not theo and
she's just like hanging there with her
hand like that being like some something
was holding her hand and she didn't know
what it was but it's just kind of like
[ __ ] like that like the and the
creepiest thing one of the creepiest
things too is like when they're all down
in the um in the uh the lounge or
whatever it is and they hear that
horrible booming again and then there's
just this great great shot where just
the door to the place just starts like
bowing like outward like that like it's
breathing or something like that it's
just such a great visual and it's just
like so simple but it's just really
really creepy you know what i mean it's
just like a creepy creepy movie so at
some point
after all this like shenanigans have
been going on dr markway has started to
suspect that maybe uh this isn't the
best place for eleanor because as i said
she's very vulnerable she's had a couple
of things where she almost like fell off
a balcony and you know things like that
because she's like oh this house it's
you gotta watch it every minute she says
because it's kind of and so he starts to
suspect that probably she's in danger
and probably she should leave at which
point she gets very very upset because
like i said she's kind of gotten to this
[ __ ] up point where
she thinks that this is her place now
that she belongs here and she doesn't
want to leave because she kind of feels
like oh they're they're rejecting her
you know what i mean she's very like i
said she's very emotionally she's a
little bit infantile kind of it's that's
maybe like a little bit of an
exaggeration but
she just kind of feels like you know dr
markway is not telling her to leave
because he thinks she sucks he's telling
her to leave because he thinks that
she's in danger because this house is
targeting her vulnerabilities and she
doesn't seem to be entirely aware of
that um and he doesn't want her to get
hurt but in her mind you know oh you
guys are rejecting me um you know but
this is my place i belong here so you
can't make me leave uh which ends up uh
ending very very badly
another thing that uh spurs onto the
thing is like near the end of the movie
dr markway's wife grace arrives who's
played by uh the same woman that played
money penny in most of the early sean
connery james bond movies so there's
that i can't remember what uh the
actress name is but i'm sure someone in
the comments will remind me what it is
but uh so grace shows up and she's just
like what are you even doing here like
you you know she's very very skeptical
and she's kind of like i heard like you
were having problems up here so i'm
gonna like come and like sort some [ __ ]
out so she gets there and like i said
nell had kind of started to develop
feelings for dr markway and thought that
he was developing you know romantic
feelings toward her as well even though
he was just mostly like kind of
paternalistic of unclear he just was
more concerned about her like as a
person not so much but she kind of
misinterpreted that because she's sort
of naive
uh so she didn't even know he was
married so when his wife turns up she
gets like super super upset because she
now she's kind of like oh that's why you
want me to leave now that now this woman
is replacing me like taking my place in
the house now
even though so grace is like super
skeptical like i said but so she's like
where's like the the most haunted place
in the house and eleanor being an
[ __ ] because she's like jealous tells
her oh it's the nursery like the nursery
is they haven't even been in there
because like the the feeling or the vibe
around it's like all covered with like
cold spots and stuff and it's just kind
of like everybody like i said you know
theo and nell
who both have kind of like a psychic uh
feel to them you know they they can feel
things they're just kind of like yeah
we're not going in there because that's
like they i think they call it like the
evil heart of the house or whatever so
nell like pipes up and is like oh you
should totally sleep in the nursery yeah
that's and you know dr mark way is like
no just like what the [ __ ] are you even
talking about and but grace of course
picks right up on it oh well if this
house is haunted i guess i'll figure it
out i'm gonna go in the nursery and
sleep all by myself and promptly
disappears so
so not so much but yeah so as it goes on
like i said um there comes like a really
intense scene too where
nell is essentially
like i said it's almost kind of like the
house is like possessing her or
you know she's almost like i said
they're they're kind of making a
parallel between her and the companion
because
the companion who hanged herself in the
house earlier was also a caretaker for
an elderly woman just as nell had been
with her mother and uh you know didn't
really have much life of her own so
they're kind of like trying to draw a
parallel so there's one point toward the
end of the movie where eleanor is
climbing up this you know rickety-ass
staircase in the library almost as
though she's going to repeat you know
the the companions actions like she's
going to hang herself from there but she
is actually rescued uh by dr markway
in this really like tense sequence where
it looks like the staircase is gonna
like fall off the wall or whatever and
at that point she actually like looks up
is in and there's not a lot of jump
scares in this movie but there's like a
really great jump scare where you know
she's up at the top of the
spiral staircase and she looks up and
there's a trap door and then suddenly
grace is up there like looking all
[ __ ] up like i said she's been missing
for several hours they've been looking
through the house for and everything and
she just like kind of pops out like like
and she didn't know where she was and so
there's all this other kind of stuff so
at this point they're kind of like okay
uh dr dr mark way and everybody else
agrees it's like look nell really has to
leave she's starting to lose her marbles
uh you know we don't want to be
responsible if she gets hurt because
like i said she was climbing up on this
[ __ ] staircase she could have fallen
she could have committed suicide like i
said like the companion did so they're
like okay well just no no more like
arguing you are leaving and she of
course you know vociferously does not
want to leave this is my place you know
why why is grace taking my place and
stuff and they're just like look chill
we'll find grace she's in the house
somewhere just get in your car and get
the [ __ ] out of here because this house
is
not good for you you know what i mean
you're gonna get killed basically so it
ends up like i said i i don't feel bad
like i could feel bad about spoiling it
i don't feel bad about spoiling it
because this movie is like super old and
like i said the book is also uh really
old and i think most people know how
this ends um essentially eleanor ends up
not leaving hill house because
it's left ambiguous at the end but as
she's leaving uh the grounds in her car
either the ghosts of the house take over
and like kind of steer it because it
kind of looks like she's like what are
you doing what are you doing like like
she's fighting with the wheel but then
later like after like the car crashes
into a tree and kills her
and then when you know all the rest of
the ghostbusters like come down there
and you know look at it luke says it
looks like she deliberately drove into
that tree
and so now the implication being that
now nell is also dead and
will remain in hill house just the way
she wanted to i think they might bring
this up in the movie but i think in the
book there's like a big thing where like
it's a part of a poem or song or
something like that that nell like keeps
repeating to herself um journeys end in
lovers meeting and so she essentially
thinks that hill house
belongs to her and that she doesn't want
to leave it ever so the fact that it
ends that way but it's almost kind of
like the house manipulated her into
thinking that so she would kill herself
so that she would stay there it's almost
like the house is kind of like uh
gathering souls into itself so it's
almost kind of like a hungry house what
they would call it like in the shining
or uh something like that where it's
trying to like gather souls to itself
like to make itself stronger so i kind
of feel like it's that and honestly like
stephen king has even said that the
shining was partially based on you know
or inspired by uh the haunting of hill
house uh as was his later book rose red
which actually i think was initially
supposed to be
uh another like a remake of the haunting
of hill house or the haunting in the 90s
or 80s or 90s and he had written a
screenplay for it but they never ended
up making it back then so i think that
later he turned that into rose red which
is kind of like the haunting but not
like he changed it a lot now let's talk
a little bit about
they did do a remake of this movie in
1999 with liam neeson and lily taylor
and catherine zeta-jones and owen wilson
and oh boy does it suck it is so so bad
i remember going to see it in the
theater
because i was very uh i was just so
apprehensive about seeing it because i'm
like man the haunting from 1963 it's so
great it's just such a great movie you
know it's like are they going to [ __ ]
this up oh yeah they [ __ ] it up big
time so it was directed by yon dabant
and basically
it took it changed it's weird because
they changed like the whole story they
didn't change the whole story it's still
like essentially the same story but they
changed like the motivation behind it
but it's like in the original
movie and in the original book you know
this is a group of like
essentially paranormal investigators
they're coming to like you know
investigate the haunting and see if this
place is haunted um you know he's a
parapsychologist or whatever in the
remake they made it so that liam neeson
who they changed his name to marrow or
maro or something like that instead of
markway whatever he was like doing he
said he was doing a sleep study and had
all these people that were like
insomniacs and he brought them to this
like horribly like haunted house
but really he was studying fear i was i
don't know it didn't make any sense like
why the [ __ ] would that happen i don't
know but the dumb thing about the remake
is that even though the inside of the
house looks like super cool and
everything
they basically took everything that was
awesome about the original movie and
about the original book as in less is
more like we don't show anything but
it's still [ __ ] scary
and it just was this explosion of cgi
[ __ ] i mean
there was just like what there was like
a bed that turned into a big spider
there was just like there was that whole
thing of like you know curtains blowing
and like turning into big faces and she
like was just ridiculous it was just so
i just feel like you know the late 90s
or the early 2000s i just feel like
every like a lot there were so many
horror movies that came out there were
just these big cgi suck fests and this
is just kind of like one of the worst
examples of that i just remember even
back in 1999 when i saw in the theater i
just remember being so so angry because
i was like did you not
get like the whole point of the original
book in the original movie was that it
was scary without having to show
anything you show all these ridiculous
cgi ghosts running around in people's
faces and [ __ ] like that it's not scary
it was just like stupid and over the top
and it was just like so dumb and i was
just like so so [ __ ] disappointed in
how
like lame that movie was and how it just
took everything that was awesome about
the original just like did a big [ __ ]
diarrhea [ __ ] all over it and it just
made me so i can't remember
seeing a movie in the theater that made
me as mad as that except maybe the rob
zombie halloween remake but that's a
whole other video but yeah so
honestly the 99 remake is just it's so
bad and it's like i would just would not
recommend it it's like despite like
they're being good actually like i love
lily taylor i you know and i've liked
most of movies i'm not a big fan of owen
wilson but you know but the other two
actors fine uh so they had a good cast
and like i said the you know the
production design and stuff was nice but
it was just
pointless i didn't see it was just like
a pointless stupid cgi wankfest and i
just like couldn't stand it and i hated
it um and i even watched it again later
just to make sure
that i was like well maybe i was just a
little bit too hard on it but nope i
liked it even less the second time so
you know but yeah so definitely if
you're into horror movies at all
and you want to see one of the
foundational
horror movies from the 1960s
particularly as concerned with you know
haunted house type stories and like i
said a lot of the tropes that came from
the haunted house stories you know that
were in the haunted house stories like
later like particularly in the 70s
because i feel like this was super
influential i also saw a video too where
i hadn't actually realized this but um
they pointed out they're like you know a
lot of the camera work in this like a
lot of the weird skewed angles and a lot
of the weird like kind of weird strange
close-ups and the way they use these
super wide-angle lenses so like the
outsides are all distorted and stuff
like that just to kind of give you this
whole sense of unease he said that's
very like sam raimi uh obviously was
really into this movie because you can
see that he was uh that a lot of his
camera work was kind of like influenced
by a lot of the camera work in this
movie and i hadn't really realized that
until i was thinking about it and then i
was like oh yeah i guess so because like
i said this that obviously
you know in the haunting 1963 it's not
like these big wacky woo kind of [ __ ]
like that but you can definitely see
where sam raimi probably got the idea
for some of these kind of skewed um you
know there's even a couple shots in
there too like where like in evil dead
for example like where they show like
shots of like the cabin and then like
you can hear these banging sounds and
that's kind of taken pretty much exactly
from this movie because that's kind of
what you know what like i said this is
they don't really show anything this is
mostly like sound design and camera work
um and just cinematography that kind of
makes you it kind of [ __ ] with your
imagination and that's like the best
kind of horror movie to me and that's
why this is still
easily easily one of my favorite horror
movies of all time if not my favorite
horror movie of all time i can just
watch it over and over and over again i
love the novel as well
and i was so excited i finally wanted
i've been wanting to do this for a
really long time
but i don't own it and uh then shutter
added it uh just probably like a week or
two ago and i was like so jazzed and i
was like oh my god that's the next one
i'm gonna do uh because i love this
movie and i've loved this movie for such
a long time so definitely if you have
shutter you know you really need to
watch this this is one of those must-see
horror movies it's right up there with
like psycho and the exorcist and all
that all that kind of stuff the
innocence um you really this is one you
really need to see if you're like any
kind of serious horror fan because it's
just a beautiful movie and just a
wonderful it's just this the ideal like
haunted house movie which we're not
showing anything but it's still like
scary as [ __ ] it's like really really
creepy and uh it's just the
psychological element and her character
and it's just like the the inner play
between all the characters it's just so
fantastic so yeah and especially if
you've watched the netflix series and
you want to see a movie adaptation
that's actually much closer to the novel
although like i said i'm not [ __ ] on
the netflix series because i really love
that
but it differs a lot from the uh source
material so if you want to actually see
like a pretty faithful adaptation then
definitely check this out like i said
it's on shutter and it's i'm sure you
can probably get it other places too but
shutter just added it so that's why i'm
doing it right now but yeah so that will
do it for this flickers of fear and i
will see you guys on the next one
bye